Can you tell us a bit about what happens during those three toes in the cove who were obeying what are people actually
come around about. Well. First of all i'd have to say that the council of all beings can consist of almost anything.
That is congress and with the ideas that i've expressed. Being in harmony with the earth. That.
What we found is that it's the intention that.
Any time a group of people gathered together for a few hours or a few days. To share with each other that ending.
Of the illusion of separation from the earth to share with each other our love for the earth
and our desire to be more powerful and. More empowered in the defense of the earth.
This miracle takes place that we experience this that we experience. An awakening.
That we experience an embodiment of this.
But having said that the particular cancelable beings that are laid you know so different.
There are hundreds of people now that facilitate these workshops around the world i just did.
In the last eight months i've done like twenty in the united states and half a dozen in russia and others in holland
and. Findhorn in scotland and other places and. Everywhere people are studying with me and.
Studying with each other how to do this. And everyone can do it differently. You know. But the way that our do it.
We usually start with the intention we make our intention very clear.
Because that's what the whole experience is based on. Then we may go into.
Various processes that help us to feel bonded with each other
and to feel safe with each other then we go into mourning
or grieving process because what we've found is that unless we are prepared to feel the pain of the earth.
We can't really be empowered in the healing of the earth as long as we deny the feeling quality of what's going on as
long as we deny the pain and horror and the. Despair and the right age. That what's going on which.
All of us feel deep down but most of us repress. Then.
We're kind of numb to what's going on so we invite us to feel those things and. From there we go.
Perhaps to an evolutionary remembering where we reenact the evolutionary drama. From the big bang.
Matter and space and time being created in the creation of galaxies and then our own galaxy the milky way.
Within that the sun and its planets. And then on the earth the earth cooling. And the crust forming and.
The development the first cell. The evolution of that cell.
Through the oceans you know like ninety percent of organic life was in the oceans
and in the last ten percent of the time. We. And phoebe ins came to the earth became reptiles and then.
Some of those reptiles. There skiles.
Turned to feathers and they became the birds and other reptiles their skulls to and.
And they became to mammals and that was our lawn. And we just try speck. Our story.
But now it's not just written history that we're identifying with but our whole story the story that's.
You know denied it's in every cell it's in our blood. And we try and. Embody that as much as we can and.
To experience that not just as being another story that we learned at school.
But that's my story that's my creation myth. I wasn't created by an all man with a white beard four thousand years ago.
You know. I've been here for four thousand million years evolving on this earth. You know and just to leave that out.
And then finally we find an ally in nature
and non human being that wishes to speak through us in the council of all beings that maybe an animal or a plant
or a sound. You know maybe the rain or the scar is some natural.
Anything but human being anything on the earth but human we know all about what humans have got to say. But.
All of these others are the voiceless ones they're the ones that.
Our culture doesn't hear anymore in fact we don't even believe that they have any voice we think that they just like
machines and so you know we treat animals like machines
and plants like machines that have no sol they have no feelings and.
The fact that they have been evolving alongside of us for four thousand million years is ignored.
So we find an ally and then we make a mask. To represent that ally.
And then finally we gather in the council of all beings without masks on and.
We just in fart out personality to get out of the way for a little while. And we spontaneously. In far.
This being to speak through us. And the matter has seen equal or skeptical we might be to start with and of course.
Most people from the modern world. You know.
Be very very surprised if anyone came to the cancellable breaks for the first time without being highly skeptical about
what was going to happen maybe this is just. Psycho drama maybe this is just a projection of our own personalities.
But always. Everyone is incredibly moved by what takes place and it's different every time.
But always we hear voices from as self saw from each other that we've never heard before with incredible wisdom
and points of view.
That a totally alien to what we've never heard before and it makes us realize that we can then speak for the.
Because we've heard the. We.
If we've had an authentic experience that we really believe that we've heard the earth speaking through these other
beings. Even through our own voice. Then. It's really easy to go up to parliament house.
And you know have someone say well you know my constituency represents.
Thousands and thousands of people who you to tell me what to do. And we can say. Listen mark constituency. Represent.
Hundreds of thousands and millions of species and they're not even represented in your palm and. You know.
They're not even represented. And i speak for them. You know. And to speak with a strong voice because you know.
We know that we're speaking for these. Voiceless ones these. You know. Best of creation which is being ignored.
Which is being shoved out of the way. And.
The thing is that once we recognize that in spite of the two thousand years of.
Judeo christian belief for four thousand whatever it is years.
Of believing that the world is a pyramid with human beings on the top.
And that the world just consists of human beings and. Resources do you know that it's just there for our satisfaction.
In spite of that. It's not true. The world is more like a web. And we humans are one strand in that way.
And if we destroy those other species then we destroy ourselves. So we all know that to be true.
But we don't know how to live that truth we don't know how to change our lives.
And the cancellable brings is a way of bringing that truth. To loft bringing it. And. Changing as selves.
Not on the level of ideas but on the level of values and on the level of life style and behavior.
What about the terms who are your thing and. Region during the employer but something else that you bring to well.
These are similar. Yeah real thing. And really gendering. To other. Workshop forms that. After vell up with.
Many friends that i work with on these things and. Use different techniques. To bring about the same effect.
Of a deep experience. Of cooperation and communion with the planet. In these workshops we use the breath.
To bring us deep into parts of ourselves
and levels of ourselves that we usually unconscious all of these techniques are based on a.
Therapy that's called rebirthing. Where the breath is used to bring.
Unconscious material from the personal part of our conscious things connected with traumas that we had early on in our
lives that we forgotten about repressed. And when we remember them the healing takes. Place.
So by adding a planetary intention and a deep ecology perspective and some other things. These other forms.
Allow us to bring this. Other area that we're totally unconscious of which is our organic nature.
I mean freud found a hundred years ago that we are unconscious of our sexuality. But that's the tiniest part of it.
We are conscious of their organic being aware and conscious of the fact that we've been evolving here for thousands
and millions of years we are conscious of the fact that the food that we ate. Means that the earth. Is our body.
That every time we place. You know. It's like there's this incredible sokal. Where the earth.
Samhain the recklessly grows. These things. And we take these things from the earth and we place them inside our body.
And they become our body. And then. We take a shit and.
The earth in our body goes back into the earth again and there is this incredible cycle of. Earth.
Which is flowing through us streaming through us. And we just started out as this tiny cell.
You know mother's body and we grew there from this earth. And we came out of our mother's body.
And we grew and grew and we are my verse. Yeah. This isn't controversial i don't see it but we don't.
Experience ourselves in this why this isn't part of our identity. Same with the water. There's this incredible sokal.
Where water is lifted up by the sun. And it falls and on its way down it lubricates and creates all of life.
Including us a tiny part of that water. Passes through our body becomes our blood and all of our fluids.
And then we piece it out. Back into the cycle again and.
The air cycle is the same so we are the intersection of the sokal and.
If you have a profound experience of that as being. Actually that is who i am. You know. I'm not some december.
Spirit that somehow trapped in this body. I was brought here from outer space. I am an earthling. Part of this.
If we feel that deeply.
Then it changes the way we behave it changes the way we think so re earthing
and regenerating of ways of bringing about those changes. So that we spontaneously through the breath.
Haven't experienced the changes their identity. Do you feel like. Developed to help develop a new religion or.
Just hope people will discover old ones. Well it's certainly.
It's certainly an old one but in this case i think that it's not just right and i don't get it started yet.
I think that there is a new religion that's being born here. But it's not just religion.
It's it's it's very much in harmony with all of the findings of science. At this time do you know and.
It's also not very new because. This is rediscovering things that area ancestors knew about and.
In particular it's rediscovering a lot of the things that were. That were deliberately. And violently.
Repressed in our society by. Thousands of years of. Judeo christian conditioning.
And most recently perhaps by the inquisition. When no and median.
European women were burned at the stake for their love of nature and for their belief that the earth was a large
and that the world didn't belong to man. And to the spirit. But that the earth belonged to. You know.
All people into the body and. To itself.
You know and so the ritual and ceremony a life that allows us to experience ourselves.
As part of the earth was repressed at that time. What are people who. You know who would say that.
What we've just been listening to. Was a lot of old hippie drivel.
Well you know i feel a little bit sorry for them because i feel my so i don't. Yeah.
Well for those people who feel that. You know that all of this is just a load of old drivel.
I feel a bit sorry for them because i feel that there's a remarkable challenge
and a remarkable opportunity at this time. For human beings. To get real. You know. To get in harmony with the earth.
If we don't do it. We're going to be destroyed and.
It's an amazing thing to be living here on this earth for four thousand million years to have survived the most
incredible challenges can you imagine their ancestors the fish. Learning to walk on the land. You know.
The incredible challenges that we faced. Of ancestors surviving ice after age and.
All of them survivors all of them finding a way through. Passing this precious precious flame of life.
From feelin to claw. To paul. And into our own hands. And then now. We're going to fumble. And let it drop.
You know what i mean. It's an incredible thing.
And so i feel that show people to be so busy playing it business as usual and holding on to those stupid ideas that.
We've developed in the last few thousand years. And letting that beautiful flame drop. For water.
You know for a marker a way of auburn and a second. Electric toothbrushes you know. Such a shine.
So i just feel sorry for them and. I myself don't believe that the earth is going to die i know that you know i mean.
The miracle was here before human beings came along. And it'll be here after they've gone.
The miracle was here before organic life started.
There was a time when there was no organic life on the earth there was just start asked you might side you know.
And eat. Was of itself. Into organic life and into us. And so that miracle. We can't touch that so i'm not really.
Ultimately i'm not despairing because i know that. That is totally secure and totally safe.
But i must say i love this organic law if i love. This. Flesh and bones and blood and breath and. Air.
And all of this consciousness. And i would be very very. All struggle with all my margin. To protect it.
And to keep it going and. You know it's a feel enriched and i have a joy in my life because of these realisations and.
I see the tremendous and happiness in. You know the faces in the lives of most people and.
Tremendous and happiness in their relationships and their. Their inability to love each other or to love themselves.
That i just think people would be doing themselves a favor to. You know look at these thing seriously.
Can i get a definition of the. Aquarius vision. Well the aquarius vision. I just think that it's.
Getting back to our roots. So and so thanks very much. Friday and thank you. Thanks but that was growth.
I carry into this.